Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and
that number is two one nine two David Pakman
in the wake of the Magots, allegations of
possible statutory rape and child sex trafficking
and so on and so forth.
We had a great caller with advice.
This is important advice.
This is important advice for anybody in the
audience if you want to avoid being charged
with statutory rape.
OK.
And I think most people would want to avoid
being charged with that.
Here is a caller explaining to you how to
do it.
Take a listen.
Speaker 5: All right.
This is Jane from Pennsylvania.
Right.
There is one sure way for a man to avoid being
charged with statutory rape if you don't know
her well enough to know her.
Correct.
They don't have sex with her.
Speaker 1: Wow, what a vote.
I don't know why I love that call.
I think it's the delivery and the accent and
it's just absolutely perfect.
Yeah, that's good advice.
And now, you know, there will be you hear
about these stories where one one the accused
will say they lied about their age.
They just lied.
And you know the difference, if I'm if I'm
30, the difference between a 17 and an 18
year old is not obvious.
And what am I going to do, check for I.D.
or something?
So you'll you'll hear those stories.
But generally speaking, this is good advice.
And I mean, in most cases, wouldn't you be
able to you know, if you're.
I don't even want to speculate, but the point
is you would learn the truth of someone's
life and like if they're going to high school
rather than college or whatever, you would
think that these cases of I was really tricked
by someone claiming to be of a certain age.
Those seem like they would be relatively rare.
And I think that the advice there from Jane
is quite good.
We've got a great bonus show coming up for
you today.
We will talk about pro tax billionaires who
are protesting not in front of Jeff Bezos,
his house, but in front of Jeff Bezos is many
homes.
OK, that's a protest that protects millionaires,
are undertaking no to the Supreme Court, is
restricting police authority to enter homes
without a warrant.
And we will talk about the circumstances.
And number three, a new study from the World
Health Organization finds that overwork has
killed more than 700 and 45000 people in a
year.
This is why we do our six month vacations
that we are so well known for.
This is a real issue and it's more an issue
in some countries than in others.
And we're going to talk about the cultural
aspect of it.
We're going to talk about the physiological
But three quarters of a million people in
a year believed to have died from what is
being described as overwork.
And we will talk about all of those stories
and much more when I am joined by producer
Pat on today's bonus show.
We may even give some awards out to the bonus
show today, get instant access by becoming
a member at Join Pakman Dotcom or becoming
a patron at Patreon dot com slash David Pakman
show patrie on dot com blocked David Pakman.
So I'll see you on the.